hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be talking about
the fact that there's no such thing as a
knife fight
what does that mean
all right so today we're going to be
talking about all kinds of knife stuff
and what happens in knife situations
uh it should be a really really fun
video um
i like to say that there's no such thing
as a knife fight and that's a little bit
of provocative
language on purpose and we're going to
explain today what i mean by that why
there is no such thing as a knife fight
also we're going to do some live
training for you guys
we have some super deadly sharpie
markers here
so we're going to use these guys to find
a make a real blood bath out here
and then we're also going to use white
t-shirts
uh i'm not endorsing either of these
brands by the way but uh so
um we're gonna have white t-shirts we're
gonna have markers we're gonna see
visually where this knife strikes are
going right and they won't be knives
it'll be markers but
we'll be seeing where the strikes are
going and we'll be able to kind of judge
that so
we're gonna talk about a bunch of knife
theory right now and then we're gonna
get josh and maya out here and we're
gonna talk about
how this actually plays out in live
situations
here we go all right there's no such
thing as a knife fight
what does that mean so it's provocative
language on purpose
i'm not saying that there's never been
situations where
two people have knives and they attack
each other that has certainly happened
but it's not the same as a fist fight or
a sword fight and so when we say
knife fighting we have a tendency to
drop this idea of two people dueling
like they would in a boxing match
or like they might do with swords but
knives are very different for
a really important reason so a knife
fight doesn't really exist there's only
kind of two people murdering each other
with knives
and we're going to talk about that you
can see we've decked maya and josh out
in super sweet outfits here so we can
see how that plays
out we're gonna do some live training
before this video is over but
first we're gonna do some theory and
talk about what i mean by there's no
such thing as a knife fight so if i was
fist fighting here with maya so we're
here in a fist fight if we are roughly
the same size
every time i hit maya maya can hit me
back right so uh we hit each other back
okay now that means that we would just
be pounding each other to oblivion
and it would be terrible and so that
really wouldn't be a fight the reason
it's a fight is because one person can
resist the shots of another
so for example if maya were to hit me
and i were to return shot here maya can
cover and her
arm has the ability to resist my blow so
i can't hit her as hard as she hits me
and the the kind of superficial damage
she would take on her arms
doesn't compare to the damage that i
would take on my body or on my face
so it's a fight because one person can
use
the ability to resist damage and deal
greater damage so we're fighting it out
we're resisting each other's what's
happening
but we can have a resistance and an
attack and it can kind of go back and
forth and so we can really have a
struggle with that okay
if i had swords with josh movie magic
all right
so if we were talking about a sword
fight how does a sword fight different
than that right so
if josh had a sword and i had a sword
these weapons are long so we got really
really long weapons here all right so
now the same rule applies because it's
just a rule of range that if we've got
if we're equipped
roughly the same every time i hit josh
josh can hit me so this is bad this way
if we fought like that
that would just be us murdering each
other wouldn't really be a fight there's
no way to resist that just
us murdering each other with swords but
because of the way the sword works
if josh were to take a high line attack
on me and i returned this shot towards
josh's head you can see he naturally has
a defense
that's because the length of this sword
will take care of that now because of
the angles of his body
that he can take when he takes a high
line attack if i swipe at his low body
you can see i can miss his low body
right so i can't attack his low body
because i'm not long enough anymore
right that's because he has a better
geometric angle than i have however
head because the sword can defend his
head so that means in a sword fight
josh can really strategically place his
shots
so that way i can't return as powerful a
blow as he returns towards me
and so instead of us just being
murdering each other with swords we can
actually have a fight one person can
resist the blows of another person and
we can have a struggle that goes on for
a while right so
that ability to resist is what makes the
fighting happen now if we had knives
then now knives more movie magic so
knives will be different right so
because of the rules of range if we're
equipped roughly the same
every time i'm in range to attack josh
josh is in range to attack me okay
with knives because the weapon's so
short i can't create natural opposition
right so
look i might be able to take a superior
angle right so i've cut josh and josh
can't get my low line right can't get my
low line but he can get my high line
because nothing's stopping his arm right
so there's no
lengthy weapon in there to stop him from
making a high line so i can take
nice good angles but the angles really
don't save me from him being able to
counter attack
now people who are really into knife
work will will argue that there are
really good angles you can take those
angles are super fine angles
and so while it might be possible for
some elite expert to get to that
level you're probably never going to
right if you have a regular nine to five
job and you're doing normal life stuff
and you train martial arts on the side a
little you're probably never going to
reach this elite level
i would argue that that elite level
really doesn't exist but that's a little
argument we could have
the truth though is in a general sense
you're not going to be able to stop
that weapon because they're they're both
short weapons right so we can't really
have a fight what basically just happens
is i stab josh
josh stabs me and this just goes on and
on i cut josh josh cuts me
now maybe we got lucky and we cut him so
bad that they die first and i only get a
little cut
that can happen but that's a roll of the
dice and we don't want to look at those
rolls of the dice
at least as much as we can get away from
looking at him okay so now
let's put together a live situation
where josh and maya have a knife fight
and we're going to do it with markers so
that way you can see what kind of damage
they end up doing to each other
but we're going to see how it turns out
not how knife fighting turns out for
these guys
okay now neither one of these guys are
super master
knifemen and we're not trying to
represent them as super knife experts
right
what we are saying is these are two
people who train martial arts a lot they
spar a lot
um you've seen in videos they spar all
the time and that's maybe a thousandth
of the sparring they've done in their
life right so
so they're sparring a lot so these are
active people who are used to messing
around with stuff and
and disarming and all kinds of stuff
like that so we're going to see what
happens with these two
they get in a situation where they knife
fight with each other
[Music]
well that was interesting let's see how
they actually look after that all right
so this is what both of these guys look
like after they choose to
knife fight or i would call mutual
murder
right so they did a mutual murdering on
each other so
um if we look at these rights if we look
at josh right here okay
so plenty of stuff that might he might
have survived okay lots of stuff that
probably would have killed him if not
in the moment later right or cause them
some life-changing
um things so so his rib cage ends right
about here this is all josh now if you
look at this
right so this went through right so so
these aren't superficial this isn't a
grazing little shot
josh is actually all scratched up
because the marker actually hit him so
those were deep right so that
was probably life-changing if not
life-ending right so
not a whole lot on the back there's one
deep right here by his spine
and one deep right here um next to kind
of where his liver would be
so so those are probably deadly shots
right there right
um we have lots of little bitty tiny
baby defense balloons all over
you can see this guy is in bad shape
right so like this is going to the
hospital life's probably changed
if you look at his carotid so he's dead
right like this
this is bad news like unlikely he's
going to get to the hospital well it
depends maybe he's
outside the er um but look at maya right
same thing this stuff's probably not too
terrible she's probably surviving
this stuff all probably killed her or
caused her life changing injuries right
so
this is all severe stuff right in here
really really bad for maya
bicep right bicep okay so that means she
probably lost the functionality of her
arm
plenty of defensive wounds trying to
keep josh's knives away right
okay all cuts right down here it depends
if it hit the top of her
hips here might not have done bad damage
she got in here to her kidneys
would have been really bad right side of
her body all this is bad right so
this is what would happen if you chose
to pull out your knife and
counter someone with a knife right so
unless you're some kind of super highly
skilled expert that would take
a lifetime maybe to acquire that skill
if you could ever get that skill
two people equal ability this is what
they look like after this so
that's why i say there's no such thing
as a knife fight there's just mutual
murder right you just do a mutual murder
on each other
so if you want a mutual murder then cool
you can you can believe in knife
fighting otherwise
knife fights don't exist and so you
shouldn't shouldn't try to choose to
knife fight right
okay now let's see how aikido would fare
in this situation so we're going to see
an aikido situation where maya's going
to try to implement the strategies of
aikido while unarmed so she's going to
be unarmed
she was attacked by a guy with a weapon
she doesn't have a a weapon handy
she doesn't have one on herself and she
can't find one around which is probably
very unlikely but
so she's completely unarmed and here's
how she would defend herself aikido
versus the knife
in that situation
[Music]
time all right so here's what happened
to maya after
now there's a nice slash right across
here that's her rib cage so rib cage is
from here to here
depending on how intense that was
probably wasn't a lethal shot
seems scary but a rib cage is right here
that's where the cut is
probably going to survive that right we
got a cut here
that's not bad this is not bad that's
not bad okay now this is deadly and you
can see
that's a pretty heavy marker now an
important thing to understand when
you're looking at marker stuff
is a marker a really light trace marks
you almost as much as a heavy trace a
nice different right a light trace
um just cuts you up a little bit a deep
one spills your guts out right
this one you can tell that's a gut
spiller right it's it's real heavy duty
stuff right there
now there's a really light one right
here that probably would have just
barely grazed her skin because it's
barely there
you can see the intensity came there and
it lightened up this one's a pretty
decent shot hard to tell because it's
not
super heavy so it could have been a good
cut this would definitely be
be damaging for maya okay back here we
have a cut back here this is probably
not going to stop my at all
the cut back here all boney probably not
going to stop mine now this is not going
to be fun don't get me wrong but
she's probably going to keep functioning
this is a little worrisome right because
we're near the tricep and deltoid so
if it got deep right here we can see a
nice deep spot
and then after this it kind of scutters
off so it might have been a serious shot
maybe not a serious shot
on our arms here we have a cut back here
again near the tricep a little bit scary
um we have a cut inside here anything on
the inside that's that's bad
now this is clearly a stab so that's a
knife coming into her arm right there
okay and actually we have nothing on
this side oh up here on the hands we
have lots of little shots any of this
stuff is going to be bad
it might not cost your life but it might
cost her the functionality of her hand
okay on this side this is not a terrible
shot at all
this bicep shot's a little worrisome
right so this might keep her from using
her arm correctly
this deltoid shot might not be too good
and there's a deep spot there which
means that really came in
this is probably a nothing this is
probably a nothing right so
so that's that's you can see that's what
maya uh
sustained from that and she was trying
to get away that's what she was trying
to do she was trying to do aikido so
this orange marker
was the aikido shot and here's her
trying to aikido and that's what it
looks like
okay so important thing to understand
here when maya's
doing the aikido stuff right so she's
aikido unarmed
what is her goal and and i think it's
really hard for people looking at modern
martial arts to understand what the goal
would be because
the the mindset is just well we got to
get in there and dominate someone
somehow so
how long is this going to go on how long
are you going to be doing that well if
someone were to attack you in that
situation you were using an aikido
strategy
you're trying to buy yourself time for
one of three things
either one make a clean escape right so
able to get in your car
drive away able to get into your house
lock the door able to do something in
order to actually escape
the attack so that's one thing you're
trying to do buy yourself time to get
away
two someone else to intervene right so
someone sees it the cops have been
called someone arrives
that's probably not high percentage
there but that also could be why you're
buying yourself time you can't make your
escape you're just trying to survive as
long as possible
so someone can show up and help you or
three
you get to a superior weapon platform
right
so in a modern era what might that look
like
[Music]
well that was interesting let's see how
she looks okay so here's what it looks
like after maya and the firearm so
here to here remember it's probably
pretty safe it'd have to be a pretty
serious shot to get in past this sternum
we got a carotid up here so this is bad
news right so if it either gets the
carotid artery or the esophagus it's
probably
fight ending for her right we don't have
anything else on her face
we have a shot here shot here
insignificant this is probably
um an eviscerating shot right and you
can see from here it's heavy
right that's a heavy shot so this is
probably guts spilling out kind of stuff
this is deadly right so you got your
ilia artery down here this is all bad
news down here so this is all really
dangerous for maya so those are horrible
horrible shots here your deltoid this
might maybe a fairly functional shot
here on the back of the hand right if
this that knife got in too deep here
that would be a bad shot for maya we
don't have any defensive wounds right
here
this is a nothing shot this is probably
not that horrible although we are close
to the axillary artery so it's a little
bit dangerous
um but this is mostly all rib cage stuff
right okay
and then this is that shot we talked
about earlier on this side defensive
wounds right so a little scary because
it's near the tricep
but it's not this is all bony this is
all bony these would all be fine shots
this is a little worrisome right so this
is going to be arterial we're going to
have some serious bleeding
and this bicep shot and that's grazing
so probably wasn't a very deep wound but
bicep's super worrying because she loses
functionality of her arm
so that was with her trying to use a
pistol to defend herself against someone
coming in
with a knife and just slashing like
crazy okay so those are the three ideas
when you're using the ikea strategy
that's what you're trying to do and i
know you're not trying to dominate the
other guy
and this is why it's really hard to
understand aikido from a perspective
where you want to fight with someone
and aikido we don't want to fight we
it's already a foregone conclusion the
other person is stronger better armed
there's more of them whatever
they're in better shape than we are and
so we can't fight with them we just
can't afford to fight with them all
right now
what would happen if maya tried to use
jiu-jitsu on josh so
maya's going to try and use jiu-jitsu
grappling right so maybe jiu-jitsu is a
bad thing to say but we practice
japanese jiu jitsu here so
so what would jiu-jitsu or some kind of
some kind of clinch work grappling look
like
when maya tries to use that against a
guy with a knife
[Music]
good job time okay so this is what it
looks like after maya tried to jiu jitsu
josh right so she tried to use
armed grappling or unarmed in her case
but to deal with the knife she tried to
grapple with josh while he's got a knife
and this is what she looks like after
that right
okay so these are probably superficial
all all
rib cage protected this one would
normally be superficial but if you look
it's maybe hard to see on camera but
it's really deep which means that was
probably a really severe stab that might
have got through
her chest right and so that would be
that could be a potentially very very
dangerous
all the way to here pretty pretty safe
stuff right so this is not going to be
horrible not fun but this will all
murder her right so this is this is
probably all death right so
maybe not death in the moment she might
have kept on fighting and she might have
got to the hospital on time
but this is all serious traumatic injury
right and if not she's probably gonna
have some infections all kinds of things
going on very life-threatening dangerous
so this whole area right here
is deadly and you can see she's really
marked up tons of deep stabs and you can
see maybe can't see on the camera but
this is a deep marker right so which
means he really pushed that in
and the marker really got in these are
not superficial right so these are all
serious all the way down here
this is the top the the quads that would
be bad news right
her back look at this all cut up through
here now these aren't
this wouldn't be terrible at all but
this is where her kidney and liver exist
right so so that that these could
potentially be bad shots this is all not
not bad shots at all right okay now look
very few defensive wounds right
there's one on her finger here um very
few defensive wounds there's a little
one there a little one there
but so you know she didn't get to defend
her body with her arms at all she
took it all right here right and the
reason for that is because uh that
clinch that josh was able to use
was a lot of times able to neutralize
maya from getting her arms where she
wanted
and maya was more worried about trying
to hold josh's body
than stop josh's arms right so when you
switch into that jiu jitsu mentality
it's a different kind of animal that's
going on right so
so i you can look at this for yourself i
personally probably wouldn't recommend
trying to grapple with someone who has a
knife
and this is what maya looks like after
that okay so now
we're going to see what happens if maya
were to happen to have
a long weapon what is she what if she
had a long weapon available to her right
and so this weapon's about four times
the length of josh's knife
so what kind of advantages would she
gain if she had a long weapon like a
baton
or was able to pick up a stick or
something like that how does that look
[Music]
time well that was interesting let's see
how she looks
all right so this is maya with a long
weapon versus
uh josh with the knife all right now up
here
probably fairly superficial right so
this is all rib cage sternum probably
pretty well protected
one here probably still fine nothing
low on maya right so imagine that a
long-ranging weapon
protected her belly better right so huh
that's interesting to think about
okay there's a slash coming from here to
here this is in the deltoid but this is
pretty bony probably would have been
okay but i mean it wouldn't have been a
nice cut
up here's a little scary but probably
not terrible actually this is bony
this is muscle and it's not super deep
here which means a knife probably just
kind of glanced across
um pretty basic defensive wound right
here this is deep
that would have not been fun to get but
she probably would have stayed
functional
bicep area a little scary although it
starts here where the bone is
and kind of comes into the bicep later
so not good but probably not the worst
thing in the world
nothing arterial here which is really
really nice okay here
defensive wounds again classic defensive
wounds very very common defensive wounds
near the tricep a little scary deep on
the tricep a little a little worrisome
right
and that's coming from up here lots of
little spots and speckles in here
and on the back we have nothing right so
imagine that a long weapon managed to
keep that away this is what maya looks
like
after the knife our marker or i should
say marker
knife with maya with a long weapon this
is how she looks
all right let me set down my coffee cup
here so we can get serious for a second
so you need to take in the stuff you
just saw and understand that was a very
unscientific demonstration and all this
stuff you guys should be doing it for
yourself so
we're not the last word on this for sure
you should be doing these kinds of
drills and
understand what these drills are showing
you and teaching you personally
um but this is a we're showing you some
drills that you can try and kind of
maybe some ways to work through things
all right so now you're seeing that when
someone has a superior
force right like a weapon or like a
knife and a knife is a superior force
because
uh our body really can't resist the
knife you know if you put yourself
up to block the knife's gonna go through
you and it's going to cause you damage
so we can't really resist that
when you're trying to resist a superior
force
you're going to lose okay so when maya
and josh squared up and she tried to use
her knife to fight his knife and
there's going to be a duel you see that
just sounded out bad for both of them it
was a mutual murdering right
when maya decided to try and use
grappling arts so she's going to use
some kind of grappling to get josh
that also turned out really really bad
for her right so now it's a roll of the
dice maybe she'd get lucky and get a
disarm or something
but in there she didn't and maya
practices disarms quite a bit
um so it's probably most likely what's
gonna happen if you try and dominate
with grappling you're probably gonna get
stabbed a bunch as well
and that could be life-changing right um
i think personally and you should look
at the shirts
and you should look at the video and you
should decide for yourself what you
think looks best and then more than that
more importantly than that you should be
trying these drills on your own but
to me the aikido strategy turned out
really the best and the reason for that
is because
you're not trying to engage with a force
that's superior to you
and that's an important thing to
understand because we live in a world
where it's all about dominating the
other person
in aikido we don't want a dominating way
we just don't want to be
injured and hurt ourselves and you see
when maya used aikido
unarmed the shirt had a look when she
used aikido
armed with a pistol and when she used
aikido armed with a longer weapon
you can see how those all turned out
right and she she did
better in my opinion she had fewer
severe injuries when she was doing that
and the reason is because she wasn't
trying to dominate josh
now when you see that you might say yeah
but that's going to go on all day no
she's only looking for a superior weapon
platform
help or true escape that's what she's
looking for so she has no illusions that
she's going to run in and dominate that
guy and we all tend to have a fantasy
that we are the star of the movie
and so when we fight someone of course
it's going to be terrible conditions but
we're going to come through the
adversity and win
in real life people get stabbed and die
all the time right so
you can't think of yourself as the
fantasy hero you have to realize that
getting out of a bad situation is
probably going to offer you
the best chance for survival okay so
look at those judge it for yourself to
me the long weapon
really was nice with a pistol it's hard
to tell because could maya have got
enough rounds on josh to stop him
before she got closer to him likely and
a pistol is a long weapon right
and when she actually had a physical
long weapon you can see that she fared a
little better and the reason is because
josh is constantly flinching from
something coming at him so if she had a
serious weapon
like a baton or a club or something like
that then that probably would keep josh
from being able to make as many
cuts and get to her and josh and maya's
only trying to buy herself time
her thought was never i'm gonna duel
with the long weapon it was simply
escape and when maya got locked into the
duel with the long weapon we see how it
turned out for both of them
so i hope this shed some light on it
practice these kinds of drills for
yourself
i'm christopher hine thanks for watching